[Music]
on this sunday night
finding middle ground in the lobster
dispute
the snag facing the facilitator trying
to end the standoff between
indigenous and commercial fishers i have
no intentions of
sitting down with them mail-in ballots
how advanced polls could change the way
elections take place in canada plus
havana syndrome
global news uncovers disturbing
information about the mystery illness
affecting canadian diplomats in cuba
and mike pence on the campaign trail
despite positive coven 19
tests in his inner circle
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in nova scotia where there's
a snag
in the federal government's attempt to
broker peace in the lobster dispute
the man appointed as facilitator between
commercial
and indigenous harvesters says he's
ready to open a dialogue between the two
sides
but as ross lord reports he's facing
resistance
from indigenous leaders
the past five weeks have been full of
disturbing confrontations
including commercial fishers cutting
indigenous trap lines
and the suspected torching of a lobster
pound that did business with first
nations fishers
to rebuild trust between commercial and
indigenous harvesters
the federal government has appointed
what it calls a neutral
third party we'll have to see if we can
get people together i mean the ultimate
goal would be to get as many people
together and have a discussion that uh
with
at a multilateral level and to
maybe hopefully come up with some
resolve when it comes to fisheries
crises
calling someone in is politics 101. i'm
trying to negotiate right now to get
some
understanding of what restraint means
but 20 years after a lobster dispute in
burnt church new brunswick exposed
opposing views over indigenous treaty
rights
negotiators are back at square one and
the new appointee
is already facing resistance he's from
pubnico
he's a president of the university down
there you know he's
getting pretty thick with the fishermen
so for us there was no
unbiased decision going to be you know
made or talked about
suret admits his objectivity could
become an issue
perhaps but um i'm not going to dwell on
that piece
i've done a number of lots of work in
the past
independently this for me is not going
to be any different
i have no intentions of sitting down on
myself
i'll talk with anyone with that but uh
right now our management plan is our
main priority
and like i said i'll put in touch with
our lawyers that can
fill them onto the information our
management plan the treaties whatever
he's looking for
chief sacks says he's focused on
separate discussions with fisheries
minister bernadette jordan
and with carolyn bennett the minister of
crown indigenous relations
representatives of two commercial
fishing groups did not immediately reply
to our request for comment
it's unclear if adding an extra layer of
discussions will help reach a common
understanding
or further complicate a convoluted
dispute
ross lord global news a land rights
dispute in caledonia ontario heated up
again today when non-indigenous
protesters showed up to disrupt a march
by members of the six nations first
nation as morgan campbell explains
there are calls for the federal and
provincial governments to make resolving
land claim issues
a priority they
are two groups of people with differing
views divided by wooden barricades
and a wall of police officers we have to
fight all the time for our rights
and this is our land we need to keep
cool heads
but we can't be intimidated either a
land claim dispute has driven
a wedge between some caledonia ontario
residents and members of six
nations of the grand river who have
halted construction
of a new housing developments in the
area for nearly 100 days the honoshoni
community
has been demonstrating on the parcel of
land which they say
is theirs for these people here to come
out and say
you know that we stand with you and we
support you and we're willing
to get behind this it's an amazing thing
to see
six nations has been pushing for a
meeting with provincial and federal
leaders
the feds have been saying for five years
now that they
are interested in nation to nation
relationships and this is something that
you know we need to be pushing forward
all the time according to the federal
minister of crown indigenous relations
there has been an olive branch extended
in a statement carolyn bennett says we
have put in place flexible processes to
allow for the exploration
of new ways to achieve this goal former
ontario regional
chief isidor day says this is an example
of a number of broken promises and
commitments
from the royal commission on aboriginal
peoples
dating back to the 1990's the crown
appointed body
looked at the relationships between
governments and indigenous people
there's going to continue to be
outstanding issues that
need to be spoken through the
perspective of lands rights holders and
not so much
those that have been bound to the indian
act day says the land dispute in
caledonia
is indicative of those outstanding
issues in
canada whether it be the fisheries
dispute on the east coast or the
wetsuit whitton pipeline controversy
on the west coast these are all issues
day
says the federal government needs to
prioritize
morgan campbell global news in northern
ontario a full evacuation is underway
from the neshcandega first nation
because of an ongoing water crisis
hundreds of people have been taken to
thunder bay only about 24
remain in the remote community earlier
this month an oily sheen was spotted in
the first nations water supply
preliminary tests show high levels of
hydrocarbons
chief christopher munias is expected to
fly back to the community
to inspect the water treatment plant
tomorrow
well in bc the ndp's election gamble has
paid off the new democrats under john
horgan
managed to turn their minority
government into a majority
global bc's richard zissman who's been
watching the campaign from day one
joins us from the bc legislature in
victoria
first of all the ndp managed to pull off
a victory in a pandemic what does that
say about the ability to hold a campaign
despite the health crisis
now robin two different things here
first it's actual voting during a
pandemic for the first time in bc's
history
more people voted before election day
than on election day
one-third by mail one-third in advance
and one-third yesterday
then there's a politics of it there is a
trend emerging here in canada where
leaders who govern
through covet 19 seem to get a bounce at
the polls and this is exactly what
happened with ndp leader john horgan he
has been
almost universally praised across
british columbia for his good
management through covid19 and rewarded
with 55 seats
as of the early results coming back and
all of that
is a signal towards four years of stable
governance and the first priority for
horgan who was actually back here in
victoria working today
will continue to be managing the
pandemic
i believe the best way forward is to
make sure that government is there
focused on the needs of
individuals businesses and communities
and we're going to be able to do that
coming into the fall
and into next spring as we prepare a
budget which will be again one of the
most extraordinary budgets
ever tabled in british columbia richard
let's talk about how significant this is
for the ndp
they can get elected in the in that
province but the question is getting
re-elected so this is very significant
it sure is it's the first time in the
province's history where a sitting
ndp premier has won reelection
and the way that it was won was
substantial as well robin substantially
in metro vancouver and growing that base
into the suburbs so an impressive
showing by the ndp who are leading from
beginning to end in the polls
and clearly finished the job although
there are a lot of mail-in ballots that
still need to be counted
the thought is that that won't
dramatically change the outcome here
all right richard zissman in victoria
b.c
next up at the polls saskatchewan voters
will cast
in-person ballots tomorrow but that
province has also had a significant
number of advance
and mail-in votes there's no doubt the
kovit-19 pandemic has shifted the way
elections are conducted in this country
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is here to talk about how these
changes
could be permanent david bc is an
example
well robin the numbers are simply
staggering in b.c
as many as 30 percent of all votes cast
came in by mail and in saskatchewan on
monday it looks to be the same
a record turnout already in advance
votes and the mail-in ballots could
total more than 10 percent of the vote
i think that bodes well for the
electoral system
and for the interest of everyday voters
in our democracies
the change is being driven of course by
the pandemic we're really bending the
curve
by reducing the potential for spread of
covet 19
because people are voting by vote by
mail they're taking advantage
of advanced voting and that means that
they're spreading it out
for election day as well but this trend
is almost certain to be permanent
that's one reason why canada's chief
electoral officer stefan perot
is pressing mps to change canada's
elections law
there is a challenge there that exists
at a national level that does not
compare
provincially or locally in the 2019
general election
about 50 000 canadians voted by
mail elections canada believes that if
there is a fall
federal election four million canadians
not fifty thousand
four million would vote by mail and that
is going to fundamentally change
how campaigns work you've got to have
earlier debates
you've got to have the platform more
dialed up and
rolled out as a whole i think those
things are going to change
and to make sure that voters have time
to get their ballots and mail them back
canada's chief electoral officer is
already on record
urging prime minister justin trudeau
that if there is a fall election
it should be as long as legally possible
about seven weeks rather than the
minimum length
five weeks of the 2019 federal election
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
the canadian province's hit hardest by
covid19 released more sobering numbers
today
quebec recorded another 879 new cases
pushing its total to over a hundred
thousand
and there were a record number of new
cases in ontario
that province registering over a
thousand new infections
for the first time this could be a spike
related to
thanksgiving on the other hand this
might be an expected rise in cases
uh in the time delay between when policy
was implemented a couple of weeks ago
and now the week ahead is going to be
the most telling week is this going to
actually plateau
or are we going to see a continued rise
in cases
both ontario and quebec have imposed
tighter restrictions
to try to contain the second wave coming
up
no quarantine for the vice president
despite his close aids
testing positive
there's another outbreak of kova 19
inside the white house tonight
five members of mike pence's inner
circle tested positive for
the virus including his chief of staff
mark short
who is considered the vice president's
closest aide
but the vp is staying on the campaign
trail hoping to recapture the energy of
the 2016 election
that handed donald trump the presidency
pence has tested negative
but as jennifer johnson reports critics
believe it's only a matter of time
u.s vice president mike pence is still
on the campaign trail after chief of
staff mark short
and at least four other aides tested
positive for covet 19.
according to centers for disease control
guidelines pence should quarantine for
14 days
after being in close contact with short
but the white house medical unit has
cleared pence
classifying him as an essential worker
how is campaigning
essential work well there are the free
elections are the foundation of our
democracy so i think campaigning and
voting are about the most essential
thing we can be doing
the trump administration says pence the
head of the white house coronavirus
task force has tested negative for cobit
19 but more than 166 000 americans have
tested positive
in just the past two days we're not
going to control the pandemic we are
going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigation
are we going to get because it is a
contagious
virus but the biden harris democratic
presidential team disagrees
they are pushing for mandatory mass and
blaming u.s president donald trump
for not getting the pandemic under
control this is the
greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of america
but president trump is painting an
optimistic picture for his supporters
despite the deaths of over 225 000
americans
we're rounding the turn we have the
vaccines we have everything
we're rounding the turn even without the
vaccines we're rounding the turn it's
going to be over
but with hospitalization setting records
in over a dozen states
medical experts say the country is at a
dangerous tipping point
these cases are going to continue to
build there's really no backstop here i
don't see forceful policy intervention
happening
anytime soon dr gottlieb insists
americans take precautions immediately
to slow the spread
as people are forced to gather indoors
in the fall and winter months
jennifer johnson global news washington
europe's second wave is accelerating
tonight forcing countries to impose
sweeping restrictions before it's too
late
france reported more than 52 thousand
cases in 24 hours
a new record for that country in
comparison india
the second hardest hit country in the
world recorded 50
000 cases and brazil the third worst
affected
recorded more than 26 thousand cases in
24 hours
tonight spain is under a state of
emergency and a nationwide curfew to try
and slow the surge of new infections
the curfew runs from 11 pm to 6 a.m
and may be extended from 15 days to 6
months under the new restrictions travel
between regions
is also banned on friday spain reported
nearly
20 000 new cases of coven 19 in 24 hours
231 people died
still ahead the mystery in havana did
canadian officials tell their diplomats
to stay quiet about an unknown illness
there is new information tonight about
how government officials dealt with a
mysterious illness
that affected 23 canadian diplomats in
cuba's capital
it's been over three years since some
embassy staff came down with
concussion-like symptoms that came to be
known as havana syndrome
now documents obtained by global news
show employees were warned to stay
silent on the issue
here's mike trolley for canadian
diplomats the sun
culture and political intrigue of havana
cuba was a dream posting
but in 2017 that all changed when five
embassy staff and their families
suddenly developed medical issues that
would become known as
the havana syndrome one staffer
currently involved in a 28 million
dollar lawsuit against the federal
government
and who was given the pseudonym diplomat
allen by the courts
says he was awoken by a mysterious sound
in the middle of the night
a screeching metallic scraping noise
that just
flooded the room and uh
i listened to it for about 20 or 30
seconds
and then as it was fading
he says he was overcome with nausea and
at the same time his eldest son's nose
started gushing
blood when he reported what happened
weeks before
he says a miami neurologist diagnosed he
his wife
and two sons with mild traumatic brain
injuries
he says he was told to stay quiet the
one thing the ambassador told me that
at that time was that do not
tell any other canadians we cannot
start mass hysteria global news has
obtained over 700 pages of heavily
redacted documents related to the case
that appear to corroborate plaintiff
claims that officials were more
interested in keeping the story quiet
than finding the cause in multiple
documents officials refer
to attacks but after it was reported
that 40 u.s embassy personnel
had the same symptoms officials decided
to stop using the word
the cause of the debilitating sound is
still a mystery
one expert believes it was the mating
call of the indy short tail cricket
and when electrical engineering expert
james lin
published his theory of concentrated
microwaves produced by
military-grade weapons lynn says
canadian officials
dialed him up there are some some people
i wouldn't say who
but the some people from canada
uh had contact with me and
tried to understand uh what might have
happened or could have been done if
these people
intend to do it 15 of the 23 canadians
impacted are involved in the lawsuit
two years after their lives were
impacted the embassy in havana remains
an unaccompanied posting
meaning it's too risky for diplomats to
bring their families
microlight global news toronto for a
more in-depth look at what those
documents revealed
head to our website global news dot ca
slash global national
next the latino vote could this
demographic be the trump card
for republican reelection
for the first time the latino
demographic is expected to be the
largest ethnic minority to vote in a u.s
presidential election there are an
estimated 60 million
living in america and of those half are
eligible to vote
since 2016 latino's support for donald
trump has been growing and that could
make a difference in swing states
tonight rob malcolm reports from
california on the appeal of the
republican leader despite his
demonization
of immigrants as the sun sets here in
colusa county just an hour outside of
sacramento
these unlikely signs went up farmers for
trump
and latinos for trump despite some of
the divisive language coming from the
president
some here in this republican stronghold
would like to see
another four years let's get this man
and the republican party back on track
farmer tom's signs are hard to miss
they're located in fields next to the
busy i-5
freeway between the small town of
arbuckle and the state capital of
sacramento
my brother and i felt this is something
we could do we had
have some pretty strong feelings about
who should be our next president who
this deserves the next four years
you know the other party put this man
through hell
farmers supported trump by a wide margin
in 2016.
they're encouraged by his campaign
promises of financial compensation
federal payments to farmers are
projected to hit a record 46 billion
dollars u.s
this year this man will save america
save the constitution
and my father to prayer would be that
he'll win in 2020
and that party will take california back
in 2022.
another trailer suggests support within
the latino community
who are you voting for this election for
trump why
i mean everything he says is good i
follow what he says
he's a businessman young latinos like
javier are voting in record numbers
munoz says his family immigrated to the
u.s through arizona
he says he doesn't see his community
under attack by trump's rhetoric
and strict immigration policies well i
mean obama did the same thing right
here with deport people i mean trump's
doing it but i mean
he's trying to do it he's trying to make
them do it the right way for these trump
voters in rural california there is
still
some unfinished business get that border
wall done
they say they've got a big wide gate
there and let them come in legally
in arbuckle california rob malcolm
global news
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the uromoto river
in new brunswick thank you for watching
donna friesen will be here tomorrow i'll
see you next weekend
have a great night
you